I would like to say this watch okay I'm
Rick Harrison from Pawn Stars I probably
have the busiest pawn shop in the United
States my shop buys three four thousand
things a month I engage maybe five ten
fifteen negotiations a day being nerd be
a nerd be a nerd read read read there's
a million things out there always be
up-to-date
it's a Breitling super ocean it's a
really cool neat watch why guys buy
these things I have no idea you have a
watch that will go down 3,000 meters no
one dives 3,000 meters never get the
first price because you can ask someone
how much they want for there might be
less than your opening offer
I'm just looking to get out of it pay
for it sure watch I'd like $3,000 be
willing to walk away you're not willing
to walk away you're really not
negotiating
you're just being forced to buy
something I can't do not gonna happen
I'll give it to graphic watch the day
you start taking advantage of people
the next day someone's gonna find out
about it and they're gonna tell their
friends and they're gonna tell their
friends in order to tell their friends
and you will not have a successful
business the fair offer for a watch like
this would be right around $2,000 the
deal the deal alright let's go do some
paperwork